like from the moment at consciousness
say that they were just always appealing
to me the way they look the way they eat
the way they move the way that their
exoskeletons shine in the light when you
sort of dispel the hatred we have
towards insects you actually have a
better shot at spying xenophobia towards
different people
[Music]
I have hundreds of different animals
mostly insects I do live animal shows
where I like to showcase different
animals that are very different from us
hi everyone thanks for coming my name is
Anna Rodriguez and these are all my pets
a lot of what we think are very
dangerous animals are actually very very
peaceful and they're actually a very
limited number of insects that can do
you harm yeah please please take
anything the treatment that people give
insects is sort of what prompts me into
studying them and liking them more
because I do feel that way in a way he's
very shy I didn't have many friends
growing up as a child I felt like I was
different from a lot of children I
couldn't really understand them they
couldn't really understand me
[Music]
I've only had one friend visit my room
ever so um over here of my African twig
mantis baby Rose hair tarantula
these are quail eggs the green
caterpillars that you can normally find
in New York there are a past black
soldier fly larvae and in addition to
live animals also have a few dead ones
it's very crowded as you can tell but
it's also I think very cozy and
comfortable I keep this place at a very
steady temperature so it's around 80
degrees or so I think I had a
show-and-tell at at some point when I
was 8 years old were out I had a I think
buta larvae and I wanted to show them
off and everyone was just really
uninterested so I thought all right so
no one likes insects I guess I'm just
the young only person who does as a
child growing up I became sort of
obsessed with them my parents nurtured
that passion I first started going to
library when I was very young for me it
was just amazing because and the entire
section devoted to insects
[Music]
there's just like so much violence and
stealing in my school there are a lot of
people I just didn't want to be friends
with weekend after weekend Oh to stay in
my room and just do something
aside from socializing with people in a
lot of cases insects or crotch
it wasn't until maybe last year that I
started doing shows and really on
telling people how much I liked it it
started with a Facebook comment the name
of the band was called - moth eggs like
I lent it on the page I said I feel I
breed moths so I feel like I shouldn't
go through the show and then some woman
saw my comment and like say it it was
all her idea
[Music]
it feels like I sort of have an identity
now that I am open about what I like
[Music]
sort of like a coming-of-age story I
never really felt like I had something
yeah I thought their name I started the
show and I realized that this is my
thing
we can't really love something if you're
afraid of it
[Music]
you can't really love something if you
don't really understand it
[Music]
the fear and hatred of insects is just
the fear of the unknown
[Music]
I definitely don't regret being more
open about Who I am as a person
it's just something that I'm really glad
I did
[Music]